[Música]
alguna vez pensaste como trataron a la
primera mujer que hizo un pantalón en
lugar de un vestido
o como recibieron a la primera persona
de color que llegó a una comunidad de
personas blancas
o como le diría a la escuela que recibió
por primera vez a un chico zurdo
o imagínate cómo trataron a los primeros
a las primeras personas que se
declararon abiertamente homosexuales
como crees que les haya ido
crees que de una los recibieron
amablemente
muy seguramente no muy seguramente el
trato que recibieron estas personas no
fue nada agradable porque pues tenían
características fuera de lo común o
fuera de lo normal en estas épocas
entonces la reacción que que tuvo la
sociedad seguramente no fue muy positiva
y es que a lo largo de la historia hemos
visto que la sociedad no acepta
fácilmente un cambio
y este comportamiento se ve reflejado en
que pues en abusos en insultos en
discriminaciones e inclusive la
esclavización de las personas de color
el miedo a las diferencias ha sido un
sentimiento colectivo
pues a lo largo de la historia es algo
pues parte de nuestra sociedad y que
sigue presente hoy en día el ver las
noticias por ejemplo me llena a veces de
tristeza de ver pues que siguen
constante los abusos los insultos e
inclusive asesinatos hacia las mayores
ya las minorías y un pues un triste
ejemplo es el deceso de georg floyd en
eeuu cómo es posible que en pleno 2021
sigamos teniendo miedo a las diferencias
porque no tenemos esa apertura para
aceptar un cambio o algo nuevo
porque no está tierra y nos cuesta tanto
aceptar que no todos somos iguales y que
por ser diferentes no significa que
somos malos
porque nos da tanto miedo lo diferente
la real academia española define la
palabra miedo como la angustia por un
riesgo real o imaginario y la palabra
imaginario es la que se me queda bien
bien presente en la mente porque
pensando en los ejemplos anteriores el
hecho de que una mujer utilizar un
pantalón no tenía por qué traer
consecuencias negativas el hecho de que
una persona tuviera el color diferente
de piel no representaba ningún riesgo
para la comunidad ósea
realmente no había razón para tener un
miedo a esos cambios
hay que reconocer porque es importante
hacerlo que aunque el inicio fue difícil
aceptarlo o aceptar esas nuevos pues
esos nuevos comportamientos huesos
nuevas estilos con el paso del tiempo si
lograron ser aceptadas y hoy en día
están dentro del estándar y dentro de lo
normal en la comunidad
por ejemplo el color de la piel o el
color del cabello es muy común ahorita a
ver diferencia ya está hay quien se tiñe
el cabello de colores diferentes o el
usar pantalones en las mujeres como el
pantalón que traigo hoy es muy normal o
hay pupitres para chicos zurdos en las
escuelas pero el día de hoy yo les voy a
hablar de una diferencia que no ha
logrado ser aceptada completamente en la
sociedad y es la discapacidad
según el censo del 2020 en méxico
existen 21 millones de personas con
discapacidad aquí en el país esto
representa más del 16 por ciento en la
sociedad o en la comunidad aquí en
méxico son demasiadas demasiadas
personas
y a pesar de que cada vez hay más y más
proyectos programas oportunidades y
vamos avanzando en los temas de
inclusión
tristemente seguimos viendo la
discapacidad como algo que no queremos
vivir como algo que nos da miedo y
cuando vemos a una persona con
discapacidad lo primero que pensamos hay
pobrecitos que vida tan difícil
pero no tener una discapacidad no es lo
que hace difícil la vida lo que hace
difícil la vida es la falta de inclusión
la falta de empatía la falta de respeto
también lo que la hace difícil es que no
entendemos que una discapacidad no es
más que una diferencia como todas las
que mencionamos del cabello de los
pantalón en fin es sólo una diferencia
que deberíamos de lograr aceptar en la
comunidad
todos somos diferentes todos todos todo
absolutamente todos somos diferentes y
hay cosas que podemos hacer y cosas que
no podemos hacer considero que está
perfecto de esa manera porque porque
todos nos complementamos con esas
diferencias
hay personas que son muy buenas en
matemáticas excelentes y hay otras que
no pero por otra parte hay personas que
son buenísimas en los deportes y hay
otras que no se les da por qué pues
porque es lo dije todos somos diferentes
todos tenemos tantas tantas diferencias
pero ojo no por ser diferentes somos
menos personas sino que todos a pesar de
nuestras diferencias seguimos siendo
personas y miembros de esta comunidad
fíjate
qué pensarías
si yo te dijera que tú también puedes
ser una persona con discapacidad en tu
día a día
esa misma cara puse yo cuando una amiga
me hizo esta pregunta y al principio así
como que me saqué de onda pero ya
después no entendí y hoy te lo voy a
explicar
básicamente todos podemos llegar a ser
discapacitados en algún momento de
nuestras vidas un ejemplo muy sencillo
aquí en méxico
yo hablo español todos hablan español
todos hablamos español entonces es fácil
comunicarme verbalmente pero si yo voy a
china me voy a topar con la sorpresa de
que haya no hablan español y nadie me va
a entender ni yo les voy a entender
entonces el entorno es el que nos
convierte en personas con discapacidad
cuando pues cuando las condiciones en el
entorno no nos están favoreciendo para
desarrollarnos o para desarrollar
nuestra autonomía en el ejemplo de china
al yo no poder comunicarme en español
pasó de ser una persona
capaz de comunicarse a una persona
incapaz de comunicarme ver realmente
otro ejemplo muy sencillo es aquí en
méxico podemos desplazarnos en nuestros
carros autónomamente por ejemplo yo voy
en mi carro a todas partes pero si llego
a venecia en la zona turística me voy a
encontrar que usan lanchas góndolas y oh
sorpresa yo no sé manejar barcos
entonces el entorno me convertiría en
una persona incapaz de tener movilidad
por mí misma y quizás y estos ejemplos
sonaron un poquito exagerado pero creo
que es una manera perfecta o una manera
muy sencilla de entender esta idea que
es muy importante que la tengamos porque
porque las personas con discapacidad en
méxico se enfrentan a un entorno que no
les está favoreciendo que no les está
permitiendo su desarrollo y su autonomía
ejemplos muy sencillos cuantos lugares
sin rampas de acceso nos encontramos
o en cuanto a centros comerciales los
lugares de estacionamiento
reservados están ocupados
ahora siendo honestos una persona que
utiliza silla de ruedas jamás podría
subirse por sí sola a un autobús público
porque no cuentan con rampas y sistemas
como los de europa por otra parte la
mayoría de nosotros no sabemos ni
siquiera el abecedario en señas y no
somos ni siquiera capaces de deletrear
en señas para comunicar con personas con
discapacidad
es muy raro que incluyamos chicos con
síndrome de dawn en nuestro círculo de
amigos y para rematar son muy pocas las
empresas que cuentan con un programa de
inclusión y oportunidades efectivo qué
pasaría si les diéramos la oportunidad
qué pasaría si nos diéramos la
oportunidad de incluirnos si
estuviéramos abiertos a la posibilidad
de tener un amigo con autismo como el
personaje de esa hit en la serie de
atípicas o cómo sería si aceptáramos a
una persona con discapacidad visual en
nuestro equipo de trabajo o en nuestro
equipo de la escuela
estoy muy segura muy segura que nos
quedaríamos sorprendidos de su valor
como personas del gran desempeño que
tendrían porque el hecho de tener una
discapacidad
no les quita las otras 100 200
capacidades que sí tienen
y es bien importante que ya en este
momento nos quitemos la venda de los
ojos que dejemos de ver lo que no pueden
hacer para empezar nos enfocar en lo que
sí pueden hacer en las cualidades que
como cualquier persona tienen estas
personas
y que fuéramos también un poquito más
flexibles en lo que nosotros les estamos
pidiendo de ellos o en la manera en la
que les pedimos las cosas y hay una
frase que me gusta mucho para para
ilustrar esta idea y es que si juzgas a
un pez por su habilidad para trepar
árboles
pasará toda su vida pensando que es un
inútil
imaginen cómo los hacemos sentir porque
siempre les pedimos que hagan las cosas
de la manera tradicional como nosotros
creemos que es normal o de la manera
correcta que nosotros creemos que es y
no cerramos
completamente a un enfoque diferente de
hacer las cosas a una manera adaptada de
hacer las cosas
se me viene ahorita a la mente un
ejemplo en las cafeterías o en los
restaurantes
lo común o lo normal es hacer leer
textos textos textos textos seguir los
pasos y lograr hacer una receta de una
bebida pero qué pasa si un chavo con
síndrome de dawn quiere hacer un frappé
y no sabe leer
pues esta sería una oportunidad perfecta
para ilustrar esta frase porque porque
si nosotros le pedimos al chico el
procedimiento típico para hacer pues el
rape se sentiría inútil pero si nos
quitamos el miedo e intentamos ser más
empáticos más flexibles
podríamos tratar el recetario con fotos
con vídeos con dibujos y que creen
si lo podría lograr
estoy mega convencida porque porque lo
he vivido apoya a un chico a que logrará
su objetivo de aprender bebidas frappés
por sí mismo
y si realmente nos diéramos la
oportunidad de incluir y aceptar
pues nos daríamos cuenta
de que no son tan diferentes como
nosotros o como nosotros pensamos y que
también nos pues nos daríamos cuenta
que tienen muchísimas habilidades como
ya lo he mencionado
entenderíamos también que las
diferencias no nos dañan o nos ponen en
riesgo al contrario las diferencias que
hay entre todos nosotros nos enriquecen
nos nutren y lo más importante nos
complementan
fíjense una de las características de
las personas con autismo
es que tienen una memoria excelente pero
increíble y conozco a alguien que tiene
ese maravilloso don me complementa como
no tienen una idea porque porque yo
siempre por andar a las prisas por andar
corriendo olvido demasiadas demasiadas
cosas pero gerardo
siempre está ahí para recordarme para
decirme la actividad pendiente en la
hora y en el día en el que se necesita
hacer
y todo esto que les estoy diciendo no
fue porque lo leí o por qué no
influenciar lo dijo o lo vi en las
noticias realmente no yo soy fiel
testigo de que si se puede incluir de
que si se pueden aceptar las diferencias
y crear un entorno pues incluyente
desde hace 11 años el síndrome de dawn
llegó a mi vida
llegó junto con la hija de mi hermana
meilán y mi primera sobrina
y con el tiempo tuvimos que aprender a
dejar de tratarla como una personita
especial tuvimos que aprender a darle la
vida lo más normal posible por su bien
por su futuro y porque es lo que todos
nosotros nos merecemos cualquier persona
merece esto
con el gran amor con el gran pasión
hacia la inclusión hacia milán y hace
dos años y medio
empecé el proyecto amor 21 amor 21 es la
primera y la única cafetería nuevo léon
que es operada por chicos con síndrome
de down y autismo en la cafetería ellos
se encargan del 90% de las actividades
de la cafetería tanto recibir a los
clientes atender a cocinar organizar en
fin todo y es increíble porque realmente
lo hacen de una manera excelente de una
manera
pues con gran calidad veo en ellos tanta
pasión tantas ganas de salir adelante
tantas ganas de ser aceptadas de ser
aceptados como personas y no como
angelitos o como niños eternos y también
fuera de su horario son las personas o
los jóvenes más comunes que hay tienen
whatsapp hacen memes bromas bailan
cantan se divierten van a alberca en fin
no son más que un amigo y una amiga y es
nada más eso
y si con todo esto no los he convencido
de que una discapacidad no limita a las
personas les voy a platicar bien
rapidito dos historias de éxito la
primera es rosa isela rosa icela es una
chica muy talentosa es una chica con
grandes habilidades que en un año ha
aprendido un oficio
completo de la elaboración de bebidas el
habrían dicho el aquiles molletes en fin
además atiende la clientela y ha
desarrollado tanto liderazgo que es
nombrada en ocasiones como supervisora
temporal y se encarga de asignar
actividades a sus compañeros tú crees
que el síndrome de dawn la va a detener
otro ejemplo muy sorprendente es luz y
luz y nunca se me va a olvidar que el
primer día que llegó a la cafetería se
asustó le dio tanto miedo le habló su
mamá y se fue no había pasado ni una
hora y se fue después regresó ella a
pesar de que era muy tímida no quería
hablar no quería atender a la gente que
entraba en crisis se asustaba ella nunca
se rindió y nosotros menos trabajamos
juntos fuimos avanzando para ayudarla a
sacar su potencial y lo logramos hoy en
día
profesional en todo lo que hace
desarrolla y cocina
unas crepas deliciosas se encarga
también de todas las preparaciones
previas de la cafetería de la revisión
de inventarios incluso ya es más
sociable habla con la gente con sus
compañeros hasta llega a hacer bromas y
pues bueno en fin gracias a su
dedicación a su esfuerzo y sobre todo a
su compromiso
pues es que ella aprendió la
responsabilidad de un trabajo la
responsabilidad de un empleo y también
el manejo de sus emociones
algo que me queda bien bien claro al
verla trabajando hoy en día es que el
síndrome de asperger no la va a detener
a lograr sus sueños a lograr sus metas
y como se dieron cuenta si hablar de
este tema me apasiona y me puedo pasar
todo el día hablando de este tema pero
bueno pues antes de irme les voy a
compartir unas pequeñas ideas que
considero importantes y si ustedes se
identifican pues las hagan propias
también la primera es que cuando llegue
algo nuevo o diferente a tu vida
es normal tener miedo es normal pero no
debemos de dejar que el miedo controle
nuestra manera de interactuar o de vivir
en la sociedad
no hay que dejar que el miedo nos haga
convertirnos en unas personas
discriminantes o en unas personas malas
cuando una persona con discapacidad se
cruce en tu vida
antes de ver su discapacidad
verlo como una persona verlo como una
persona como tú y como yo con
habilidades con defectos con virtudes
como persona no como una persona con
discapacidad como persona
recuerda también
que llamarlos personas especiales ya no
es suficiente
ya no es suficiente porque la inclusión
no debe de ser vista como un acto de
caridad sino como un acto de respeto
hacia el prójimo
ya dejemos de pobre te are a alguien que
no está pidiendo nuestra caridad solo
están pidiendo una oportunidad de que
les demos oportunidades de mostrar sus
habilidades y sus virtudes gracias